[Musik]
ja hey Leute ich stelle euch heute den
Tropic craft Mod für die minecraft beta
1.8.1 vor und zwar geht es in diesem Mod
darin dass dieser Mod macht halt eure
komplette Minecraft Welt viel tropischer
viel bunter es werden hier neue Blumen
neue Pflanzen Palmen hinzugefügt auch
neue Mobs wie hier z.B schon zu sehen
und ich erkläre euch den mal jetzt von
Anfang an und zwar ist dieser Mod halt
sehr umfangreich deswegen werde ich
schnell anfangen so also die ersten MS
sind die osterinselköpfe ihr seht schon
wenn ihr den zu nah kommt dann laufen
die hier hin und greifen euch auch an
das seht ihr hier ich gehe mal eben hier
rein au okay er schlägt mich ihr seht
das
und ja der schimpft auf sein eigenen
Sprache bei euch also die können auch
lauter machen und zwar greifen die euch
halt sofort an und die droppen den Block
hier den
Chunk Chunk oh head Block daraus
bestehen auch diese osterinselköpfe die
manchmal so einfach in der Welt
rumshehen aber die reagieren nicht die
sind einfach so gebaut aus diesen
Dingern und goldblöcken also die stehen
da manchmal irgendwo rum so dann gibt es
Leguane das ist finde ich eine AUA eine
sehr elegante Kreatur die sind
eigentlich friedlich bis man die
angreift und den Fehler habe ich halt
schon vorher gemacht ihr seht das er
verfolgt mich egal wo ich hingehe und
sie greifen auf jeden Fall dann auch
zurück an wenn ihr sie angreift aber
nicht alleine sondern in einer
kompletten Gruppe also wenn W ich jetzt
das mir auf mache ihn schlage dann kommt
of eine komplette Gruppe und darauf habe
ich jetzt keinen Bock deswegen töte ich
dir mal eben so dann seht ihr schon was
der dropt nämlich hier wo haben wir da
scale aus scale könnt ihruch später noch
eine scale Rüstung machen aber da komme
ich halt später noch zu so jetzt seht
ihr nur Bilder von den Mops die ich
jetzt vorstelle und
zwar gibt es da Seesterne also ihr seht
nur Bilder weil ich die Mops kein
einziges Mal gefunden habe ich habe
einmal einen Frosch gefunden aber das
das das sch war das war wirklich am
Arsch der Welt und na ja ihr seht halt
Bilder oben rechts also da gibt es die
Seesterne das ist ein sehr trügerischer
Mod die sind friedlich beim Angriff
fliehen sie und drehen sich im Kreis
also Sie versuchen zu fliehen sie kommen
halt immer nur so ein paar Blöcke weit
findet ihr im Wasser aber die schlagen
halt nicht zurück also sind eigentlich
Fried friedlich die droppen ein Starfish
Shell das seht ihr hier
nee hier seht ihr das das hier und ja
die kann man wahrscheinlich später für
eine Dekoration nutzen meinte der
Entwickler aber geht halt mittlerweile
noch nicht so dann gibt es Baumfrösche
auch treeefogs genannt die spawnen ja
höchstwahrscheinlich auf Bäumen also die
spawen auf Bäumen und da gibt es zwei
Arten einmal die nicht giftigen Frösche
die sind grün die greifen wir euch halt
nicht an sind friedlich Sowi z.B einen
Huhn und die giftigen da gibt es rote
blaue und gelbe die sind alle tödlich
die können wirklich so stark sein wie
der stärkste Creeper ja das kann schon
mal vorkommen die Drops sind der grüne
Frosch droppt hier die Froschbeine die
könnt ihr auch kochen also Braten in
eurem Ofen dann habt ihr guckt frogl und
die könnt ihr auch essen dann füllt das
Herzen auf wie viele weiß jetzt nicht
genau könnt ihr ja
testen die giftigen droppen den poison
Skin und daraus könnt ihr euch
irgendwann poison Darts machen ich weiß
nicht ob das schon funktioniert ich habe
es auf jeden Fall nicht in too many
items gefunden aber ihr könnt ja mal
danach suchen könnt mir davon schreiben
vielleicht kommt auch erst später
genauso wie mit der Dekoration mit
diesem Seestern na ja ich glaube es geht
noch nicht so dann kommen wir zum scale
Armor dafür nehme ich mal eben meine
Workbench pflanzt die hier hin also ihr
könnt euch nämlich hier so ein Helm
machen zu der Funktion von den ganzen
Sachen komme ich später noch weil das
ist ziemlich cool das erinnert mich
alles hier so ein bisschen an
den an den slimecraft Mod das seht ihr
auch unten der ist unten in der Ding
jetzt eingeblendet so die ganzen Sachen
gibt es normal wie bei jeder Rüstung die
Boots könnt ihr euch anziehen die werden
gemacht wie bei jeder Rüstung könnt ihr
euch auch so anziehen wie bei jeder
Rüstung und ihr seid halt jetzt wenn ihr
das anhabt seid ihr einerseits hier
schick gekleidet wie eine wie eine
Schlange ja ich habe dich auch lieb aber
wenn ihr jetzt in Wasser springt könnt
ihr halt ganz lange unter Wasser bleiben
und ihr seid immun gegen Feuer also das
hat auch seine Vorteile dass sie dieses
Ding anhabt so das waren die Mops und
die Rüstung und dann guck ich mal weiter
mein Unterlagen so so kommen wir zu den
Palmen also es gibt nämlich auchs Arten
von Palmen es gibt hier die große Palme
auch large Palm genannt da sind
Kokosnüsse dran es gibt die kurvige
Palme ihr seht schon warum die kurvig
genannt wird die große Palme wird
übrigens große Palme genannt die ist
nicht wirklich größer aber die hat viel
mehr Volumen in den Blättern und dann
gibt es hier noch die originale Palme
die ist ganz normal so eine Mischung aus
den beiden oder auch nicht keine Ahnung
auf jeden Fall seht ihr das schon die
tragen
Kokosnüsse so kokosnüs
komm so da haben wir die erste und da
haben wir die zweite und da ist die
dritte und ihr braucht das gar nicht
fragen diese Blätter hier kriegt ihr
nicht mit einer Schere weg ich könnte
jetzt aber theoretisch hier das das hier
mitnehmen und könnt mir hier mit z.B
hier
einen ja ein Ding bauen so was könnt ihr
mit diesen Kokosnüssen machen die könnte
ich jetzt irgendwohin Pflanzen und dann
mit dem Schwert könnt ihr da drauf
schlagen und dann habt ihr die Kokos n
Chunks heißen die glaube ich da kriegt
ihr dann immer eins bis fün Kokosnuss
Chunks und die könnt ihr bis zu acht
Decken und die heilen ein genauso wie
Kekse das tun und die könnt ihr auch
essen ich kann das gerade nicht weil ich
volle Dingens habe volle Fleisch Keulen
oder was das unten ist aber egal also
die könnt ihr Essen und die verhalten
sich eigentlich wie Kekse auf euch so
dann kommen wir mal zu den Blumen da
gibt es hier die Ananas da könnt ihr das
einerseits oben wegschlagen dann habt
ihr äh wo ist er da habt ihr hier die
Ananas und hier wächst das dann
irgendwann noch mal nach und ich kann
die Ananas dann entweder verbrauchen
oder hier wieder eine neue Pflanzen also
könnt ihr halt so ein bisschen Farmen
allerdings wenn ihr das wegschlagt
passiert gar nichts so dann gibt es die
komelina diffusa die krokosmia die
Orchidee und die Iris die verhalten sich
alle genauso wie die gelbe und rote
Blume also wenn ich die hier wegmache
dann kriege ich die hier hin und kann
die wieder hinpflanzen und kann die
wieder hinpflanzen kann die wieder
hinpflanzen kann die wieder hinpflanzen
halt nur hier ist das anders ja wir
haben dich auch lieb so dann kommen wir
zum pinacada ihr könnt euch nämlich auch
ein Drink machen dafür tut ihr oben
Kokosnuss Chunks hin da drunter eine
Ananas und da drunter diesen Becher dann
kriegt ihr eine pinacolada so dann zeige
ich euch noch eben wie ihr euch den
Becher macht den macht ihr euch nämlich
indem ihr die bambusteile da so hin tut
und dann habt ihr einen leeren Bambus
Becher ich weiß nicht genau die
Übersetzung von MA aber halt cher so sag
ich jetzt mal einfach so dann kommen wir
weiter zu den crafting Rezepten und zwar
könnt ihr den Bambus hier so hintun ich
sag euch nachher noch wie ihr den Bambus
kriegt also keine Bange dann kriegt ihr
hier halt so ein bambusblock ihr könnt
den Bambus so machen dann kriegt ihr
Bambus stairs aber ihr könnt die Bambus
stairs auch kriegen wenn ihr einfach so
macht also macht eigentlich kein
Unterschied dann kriegt ihr halt aber
einfach nur eine Bambus Stufe und dann
gibt es noch blaa das hier Bambus slaps
also so halbe Steine von den Sachen so
und hier die Bambus stairs die sehen
halt auch so ganz normal aus so das
Gleiche kann man auch mit den sugar
Canes machen und zwar könnt ihr die so
im Kreis machen dann kriegt ihr hier so
ein Thatch Block Thatch heißt Stroh also
ich sag mal einfach Stroh weil das
einfacher ist ihr könnt den hier hinun
dann habt ihr zwei von denen ihr könnt
auch jetzt so machen dann habt ihr
wieder diese Treppen ihr könnt das
allerdings auch so machen also
eigentlich alles genauso wie beim Bambus
ähm und ihr könnt halt auch mit den
sugar cane so machen dann kriegt ihr die
und ihr habt das gerade auch gesehen ich
kann auch einfach hier so ein reinun und
dann habt ihr die auch also hier mal zum
Vergleich zack äh zack also muss halt
jeder selbst entscheiden was er schöner
findet es ist halt hast bla blaaa es hat
halt alles so ein bisschen was mit der
Dekoration zu tun und na ja ihr seht das
schon also so diese
Palmen die wachsen nur auf Sand die
findet ihr nur in der Wüste oder ihr
könnt das selber machen so wie ich ich
habe nämlich einfach einen Block
weggemacht hab da Sand drauf gesetzt den
Sapling
drauf und dann ja fertig die saplings
kriegt ihr übrigens auch von den
Blättern wenn ihr die kaputt macht so
der Bambus der wächst überall mal den
könnt ihr so wegmachen und reagiert
eigentlich genauso wie sugar can wenn
ihr das wegmacht dann wächst das hier
irgendwann nach und ihr könnt euch
Farmen machen und das Gute an den Teilen
ist die wachsen nicht nur am Wasser
sondern könntet ihr auch theoretisch
jetzt mal hier so einfach hinpflanzen
also das ist ganz cool an den Sachen und
die ganzen Sachen die ganzen Blumen und
die Tiere und Leguane und diese Teile
die findet ihr alle weltweit random in
der Welt ihr seht da hinten wachsen die
Blumen da hinten sind auch noch welche
von den Blumen und so weiter und jetzt
geht auch gerade die Sonne unter und es
neigt sich zum Ende dieses Video ich
hoffe ich konnte euch den Mod ein
bisschen näher bringen schaut auf jeden
Fall mal an der Website auf der Website
vorbei im Minecraft
Forum Link ist in der Beschreibung
download link ihr braucht dafür den
Modloader und den Audio Mod für die
Sound und halt Modloader weil der Mod
halt ziemlich groß ist keine Ahnung
genau warum man den braucht und ähm
irgendwas wollte ich noch sagen na ja
egal ach ja Tutorial wie man das
installiert ist auch in der Beschreibung
findet ihr aber auch im Minecraft Forum
und dann mit diesem schönen Blick würde
ich sagen sehen wir uns beim nächsten
Video ciao